and tonight we're continuing to remember
the american heroes lost in last week's
terror attack at karzai international
airport in kabul 13 brave men and women
from all across the country as young as
20 years old made the ultimate sacrifice
serving their country with honor bravery
distinction dignity remember we have an
all-volunteer military these brave souls
they took on this challenge these were
america's finest our national treasure
that rose to the occasion met the moment
represented the best the very best our
country has to offer and quite frankly
they deserve so much better than this
and better than to have joe biden you
know look down and check his watch
during the dignified transfer of remains
over the weekend joining me now the two
gold star fathers they lost their sons
in last week's attack mark schmitz is
the father of lance corporal jared
smith's and darren hoover the father of
staff sergeant darren hoover jr who went
by the name of taylor let me start with
you mark if i may
your son was sent back
to afghanistan to assist with the
evacuation efforts he said it's
something he always wanted to do i never
have seen a young man train as hard as
he did to be the best soldier
he could be he went back just for this
mission
explain
yes he did uh
first i i i just wanted to say that that
jared has uh
exemplified
so much that any man could ever strive
for and made me so proud to watch him
undertake this
this endeavor and going into the marine
corps and
he
completed his boot camp
went to jordan was excited about that
and was constantly looking to do more
and was given that opportunity
yeah first i want to say to both of you
if i may as a parent you know i nobody
can understand
the loss
that both of you have gone through
um
i can't imagine the pain that both of
you are living through and i'm very
sorry about that mark you met with biden
over the weekend how did that go
well initially i wasn't going to meet
with him
but then i felt i owed it to my son to
at least have some words with him about
how i felt and
it
it didn't go well
he talked a bit more about his own son
than we did my son and that that didn't
sit well with me
your son was a hero i can't imagine the
pain i really can't
darren you're said about your son he had
the biggest heart in the world
and
no parent and i
as a parent i think every parent
watching right now understands this no
parent
should have to bury their sons or
daughter it's not supposed to work that
way
he was scheduled to return home on
september the 15th
and retire and marry his fiance nicole
i can't imagine how you're feeling today
you know it's it's
it's the absolute worst feeling in the
world
um
having
having them be away for so long
and
doing the job that they they all love
there's no doubt about it
um
being a marine
to these guys is everything
and
having
this happen
to these heroes
every one of them's a hero there's no
doubt every last one of them
they
they died
with their brothers and their sisters
right next to him
doing exactly what they all wanted to do
and that is defending this country
america's national treasure that's
that's how i refer to them
yeah
you chose not to meet
with president biden i don't know if you
want to comment on that and i'd like to
know
when i saw biden look at his watch i was
literally like you got to be kidding me
because all of this to me was
preventable
because we saw them on the march
you know we we had april may june july
to extradite everybody and our equipment
we didn't do it there's no excuse to me
for this
why did you choose not to meet with the
president darren
for exactly the reasons you just gave
um
we
we said absolutely not we didn't want to
we didn't want to deal with him we
didn't want to
we didn't want him anywhere near us
we as a family decided that that was the
way it was going to be
in reference to
the
checking of his watch
that didn't happen just once
that happened on every
single
one that came out of that airplane
it happened on every single one of them
they would release the salute
and
he looked down his watch on every
last
one all 13
he looked down at his watch
and
as a father
you know
seeing that and the disrespect and
hearing from
his former
leaders
one of his master sergeants
said exactly what you just said
that
this was avoidable
that
they left them
over there they had them over there and
let them down
and that that we can't have that we it
it can't happen ever again
we also abandoned americans americans
now are on their own we left them behind
mark you want to comment on the watch
incident did you notice the same thing
yes i did i actually leaned into my
son's mother's ear and i said i swear to
god if he checks his watch one more time
and that was only probably four times in
um
i couldn't i couldn't look at him
anymore after that
just considering especially the time and
why we were there
it was
i found to be the most disrespectful
thing i've ever seen
i i know there are no words that any
commentator or host
could express that's going to take your
pain away
um
[Music]
but i can tell you
this audience shares in your anger
and
shares in a deep appreciation and
thankfulness
and sadness
had an unnecessary loss of life i
believe in this case and we'll be
praying for all of you your families
these incredible young men that you
raised that made this country the
greatest country on earth they make the
country great there are some leaders
that don't make the country great they
did
our thoughts and prayers are with you
both thank you mark thank you darren
thank you thank you sean hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else